[Music]
hi
um so my name is caroline ledbetter and
i'm going to speak to you
about how incorporating the our project
templates can help you standardize and
automate
uh your workflow so why are project
templates
if you can automate something you should
automate something chances are that you
when you do our projects you tend to
either you
as a person or as your organization has
a standardized
file structure readme that you like to
put into it
maybe you always set it up as a github
repo all of these things that are
probably unique to your workflow or your
organization
you can set this up to do that
automatically for you
every time and if you are an
organization and you set this up
it ensures that everybody is following
the same stuff
which helps you in the future
so what do you need to set up your own
our project templates
you need an r project they have to live
in our project this can be just a simple
internal project
it can live on github it can live
wherever your our projects live
you need a template metadata file and a
template function
file and i'm going to show you using our
internal cedar tools package
what those look like so i've highlighted
them here um so
your uh your project setup dcf is your
template metadata and newproject.r
is our template function and i'm going
to demonstrate how we
how we person or how we as an
organization use this functionality and
ours
so we have the ceta tools package all of
the code is available on github so after
this talk if you want to see exactly
all of these steps you can see it there
so for us we do a lot of scientific
research with an academic center
so we have principal investigators we
have analysts
we have a get lab internal server where
we usually store our stuff and get
so you can put all of this information
in here
and some of it is optionally stored in a
uh
a dcf file so that it can be uh
referenced in headers
and in snippets um and so you don't have
to keep putting
that information for each project in and
it also gives you the choice of uh
getting your repo
started
and so this is just an example of what
the uh
the template metadata looks like it's
uses widgets that are very similar
to shiny if you're familiar with that
but you can see right here
you know from the previous screen we had
the principal investigator
option it does not have a default you
can decide where it goes and in what
order
and what its label is and stuff like
that what kind of input it is
and then this is um our our project
setup function
um just to give you an idea of what that
looks like so all of those
parameters that you set up in the
previous screen are passed through the
dots argument
so you access them just like you would
access other docs arguments
through a function
and our studio has a fantastic
how-to guide of how to set these up the
website
is there if you want to check out
our repo and see exactly how our stuff
is laid out and how that might apply
to the way you'd like to set up your our
project templates
the repo is ledbet cc to tools
and then the slides for this will be up
on my website
probably tomorrow um you can reach me at
carolineledbetter yahoo.com
and you can find me on github and
twitter
[Applause]
[Music]